following the devastating and horrific
attack on our dear friend sir david last
friday
i asked each police force to review the
security arrangements for all members
with immediate effect
i am assured since i commissioned that
review that every member has been
contacted by their local police force to
reassess their individual security
arrangements in the wake of this tragedy
if any honorable or right honourable
member has not received contact then
please do speak to me after this
statement
in parallel to this review mr speaker
the joint terrorism analysis center has
conducted an independent review on the
risk-facing members of parliament
while we do not see any information or
intelligence which points to any
credible specific or imminent threat
i must update the house that the threat
level facing members of this house is
now deemed to be substantial
this is the same level as the current
national threat to the united kingdom as
a whole
so i can assure the house
that our world-class security and
intelligence agencies and
counterterrorism police will now ensure
that this change is properly reflected
in the operational posture
mr speaker i will always ensure
face-to-face contact robust debate and
the wider benefits of our democracy are
defended and protected
but we must all take this change in risk
seriously
so i would mr speaker like to urge all
members to access the range of security
provisions and support available under
operational operation bridger through
the parliamentary and through the
parliamentary security department and
the metropolitan police's parliamentary
liaison and investigation team
as well as for our own sake
we have a duty of care to protect our
staff and the general public
i know that every single member
will take register and act upon the
advice that is given to help our country
be kept safe from terror
and of course to enable our own conduct
when it comes to making sure that
democracy is defended and protected i
commend this statement to the house